[Musique]
j'ai toujours été passionné par les
étoiles j'ai toujours rêvé d'être
astronaute
est-ce qu'il y en a parmi vous qui ont
aussi rêvé d'être astronaute
je suis pas le seul et j'ai toujours
voulu voguer dans le ciel mais c'était
pas trop une bonne idée pour ma maman
qui n'aimait pas l'idée que son fils
pose ses fesses sur une grosse matière
explosive juste pour aller dans la
stratosphère
alors elle a essayé de me dire mais est
ce que tu as envie de passer des mois
dans un sous-marin nationale parmi vous
qui veulent passer des mois dans un sous
marin y en a un mais elle a nettement
moins déjà jeudi mais ça n'a rien à voir
maman tu comprends rien mais aussi en
gros tu veux te mettre dans une boîte de
conserve à respirer de l'air conditionné
séparé d'une mort certaine par une fine
épaisseur de métal c'est exactement
pareil je me suis rendue compte qu'elle
avait raison oui les mamans ça a
toujours raison mais le monsieur bouton
poser la question pourquoi pourquoi
suis-je passionné par les étoiles et
visiblement je suis pas le seul règne
dans cette salle mais depuis l'aube de
l'humanité pourquoi est ce qu'on regarde
les étoiles et pour répondre à cette
question et bien je suis retourné un peu
dans le passé près de quatre milliards
d'années dans le passé et à cette époque
la terre enfin cet endroit de l'univers
ça une soupe d'atomes qui s'est mise en
en étoile en planète mais c'est tout il
ya rien de très intéressant si ce n'est
que certains de ces atomes au hasard des
rencontres ont formé des molécules et
certaines de ses molécules ont la
propriété assez incroyable de se
reproduire
elles vont capter les atomes autour
d'elle pour faire une copie d'elle-même
alors ça entraîne que les molécules
doivent devenir de plus en plus
complexes pour arriver à faire cet
exploit et pour capter de manière la
plus efficacement possible les
ressources de la planète
mais bon c'est tout ça ça prend
énormément de temps
à l'échelle si vous regardez par exemple
si vous vous mettez sur la planète terre
il faudra près de 1 milliard d'années
pour voir la moindre différence mais
cependant j'en ai déduit une loi que
j'appelle la loi des 3 c c'est qu'il ya
on passe d'abord par une étape de
compétition une étape de
complexification qu'il résulte
directement de la compétition et enfin
une étape de collaboration ben oui
pourquoi parce que ces molécules qui
sont en compétition les unes avec les
autres
au final vont s'assembler pour former
des cellules pour former un ensemble un
bel ensemble de molécules mais qui vont
vivre ensemble et qui elle-même alors ça
dure très longtemps mais qui elles mêmes
vont entrer en compétition une
compétition féroce
vous avez des cellules qui vont
développer qui vont se complexifier qui
vont développer des organes qui vont
développer des noyaux qui vont essayer
de détruire de phagocyter les autres
cellules
jusqu'au jour où cette complexification
atteint certaines limites et les
cellules se mettent à collaborer à
collaborer pour former un organismes
pluricellulaires et là je suppose que
vous avez déjà un peu compris le
principe ayvelles organismes
pluricellulaires les organismes
pluricellulaires y rentrer en
compétition il se complexifie il se
complexifie tellement que certains vont
devenir gigantesque mais oui c'est une
bonne manière de ne pas se faire manger
demain servir de ressource pour les
autres c'était plus gros que tout le
monde est plus gros plus puissant et on
les appelle les dinosaures
la grande particularité des dinosaures
c'est qu'ils sont devenus tellement gros
qu'ils devaient passer leur vie à
trouver des ressources juste pour
survivre
paradoxalement la complexification les a
rendus trop fragile et ils ont disparu
alors plutôt que de faire des gros
système très complexe de nouveau la
solution va venir de la collaboration
certains organismes ont collaboré on a
les essaims on allait me que les
troupeaux et dans le cas d'une espèce
que j'aime particulièrement qui
s'appelle le genre homo on allait
vu le genre homo va collaborer à une
échelle supérieure grâce à l'invention
du langage et ça c'est génial parce
qu'elle que le langage le genre homo
peut collaborer avec toutes les
personnes au même endroit au même moment
on a des tribus qui rentrent en
compétition les unes avec les autres
bien sûr mais c'est merveilleux et la
période de similarités que je vous avais
dit qu'il fait un milliard d'années a à
l'époque des cellules qui est descendu à
quelques millions d'années à l'époque
des dinosaures est bien pour le genre
homo cette période de similarité des
sens a dit milan parce que les choses
vont beaucoup plus vite
la collaboration permet d'accélérer
l'innovation est ici les 10000 1 en fait
je les sors pas de trop de mon chapeau
si vous lisez un papier archéologiques
mais quand on date un squelette ont date
des artefacts généralement au tibet
voilà ça c'est vieux de cent mille en a
plus ou moins dix ou quinze mille ans ça
veut dire que si vous prenez un homme
préhistorique vous le déplacer de dix
mille ans dans son futur dans son passé
ils voient pas la différence
par contre il voulait amener maintenant
mais là il sera un peu choqué pour dire
que les choses évoluent elles évoluent
quand même beaucoup plus vite qu'avant
elles évoluent relativement vite jusqu'à
un moment où une invention du genre homo
va pas va pas révolutionner l'histoire
elle va inventer l'histoire
l'écriture l'écriture va porter la
collaboration à une échelle supérieure
désormais on peut collaborer avec un
autre être humain qui est distant d'un
millier de kilomètres ou de milliers
d'années vous avez déjà lu platon ou un
auteur mort depuis des siècles il
collabore encore avec nous grâce à
l'écriture
les tribus qui étaient en compétition se
mettent à collaborer pour former des
empires
c'est tellement flagrant que 500 ans
seulement après l'apparition de
l'écriture on trouve déjà des pyramides
quelque chose qui n'aurait pas été
possible
avant c
str ordinaire mais j'aime pas dire que
l'écriture a été inventé il ya 5000 ans
ça paraît loin comme ça où 5000 ans mais
je vous invite à un juste une expérience
de pensée imaginer qu'à côté de vous se
trouve votre maman et à côté d'elle
la maman de sa maman votre grand mère et
puis votre arrière grand mère et votre
arrière grand mère et toutes vos mères
successives jusqu'à l'invention de
l'écriture
ouf ça fait du monde et bien non ça fait
moins de personnes que ce que vous êtes
dans cette salle 150 200 personnes c'est
moins qu'un avion de ligne
vous pourriez toutes les rencontres et
tout discuter avec elles toutes vos
mères jusqu'à l'invention de l'écriture
tout ça pour dire que l'écriture vient
d'être inventé à l'échelle géologique on
est durant l'invention de l'écriture
l'écriture papier manuel de une personne
à une autre n'est qu'un prototype et il
ya 500 ans ce prototype a été grandement
améliorée grâce à l'imprimerie qui a
permis à des halles à une personne de
communiquer avec des milliers d'autres
alors si l'écriture de 1 1 avait permis
la création dans pire et ces empires se
baser sur l'écriture pour leur
hiérarchie à travers les lettres de
noblesse se basait sur l'écriture pour
définir leur vérité à travers la
religion à travers les lois et les
empires se voit soudain soudain menacé
par la démocratisation de l'écriture
grâce à l'imprimerie
que faire si tout une personne peut
communiquer avec des centaines des
milliers d'autres les idées se propage
pire les bourgeois peuvent désormais
imprimer la richesse avec des billets de
banque
l'aristocratie périclite les la religion
péricliter laisse la place à la presse
qui va donner désormais plusieurs vérité
au peuple c'est extraordinaire
et vous allez venir mais on voit
toujours pas le rapport avec les étoiles
mais ce qu'on peut voir c'est que dès
l'invention de l'écriture les gens sont
passionnés par les étoiles
tous ceux qui ont levé la main nous ne
sommes pas seuls depuis 5000 ans nous
sommes des millions et des millions
passionné par les étoiles et cette
imprimerie représente quand même un
danger pour les empires un tel danger
que l'aristocratie s'en rend très vite
compte le roi d'angleterre décide que
seule la guilde des imprimeurs pourra
imprimer les livres enfin seulement ce
que lui aura accepté cette loi encore en
usage aujourd'hui s'appelle le copyright
elle est fortement évolué mais c'est une
loi qui a été créé à la base pour
contrôler les idées pour éviter de
remettre en question le système
ça a très bien fonctionné parce
qu'aujourd'hui en angleterre on a encore
une famille royale en france ils
essayent ils sont plus qu encore plus
extrême le roi de france décident que
toute personne en possession d'une
imprimerie sera puni de mort ça marche
moins bien parce que tout simplement les
imprimeurs s'installe à la frontière
distribuer des livres et au final on a
peine quelques générations ces idées
vont mener à la révolution française et
donc tout ça pour dire que l'évolution
de l'imprimerie a mis à mal les empires
qui laisse la place aux bourgeois aux
entreprises aux multinationales
tout ça parce que on peut désormais
communiquer vers plusieurs personnes
mais c'est encore qu'une étape dans le
processus de création de l'écriture ce
qui serait idéal c'est que tout le monde
puisse communiquer avec tout le monde
instantanément il existe ça s'appelle
internet
c'est là l'étape suivante dans
l'écriture est désormais internet permet
à sept milliards d'êtres humains de
communiquer avec sept milliards d'êtres
humains
si vous envoyer un tweet là maintenant
sur twitter ou sur n'importe quel réseau
social potentiellement 7 milliards de
personnes peuvent le lire
cette conférence est enregistrée en
vidéo
potentiellement elle pourrait être vue
par sept milliards d'individus comme je
ne suis pas un chat ni un chanteur
rien il ya peu de chances que
j'intéresse 7 milliard de personnes mais
potentiellement oui ils peuvent
je peux essayer quelque chose un peu
plus osé mais alors on a donc une
opportunité si on se remet un peu à
l'échelle j'expliquais là j'ai oublié
dire que la période de similarités se
réduit d'autant plus parce que désormais
il ya dix ans personne d'entre vous
n'avez de smartphones apple sortait à
peine son premier iphone ya dix ans si
on a parmi vous qui ont une vingtaine
d'années
je les invite à passer une journée avec
un téléphone qui date de leur naissance
juste pour voir à quel point le monde a
changé
ben ma belle fille de 5 ans acquise
expliqué que caen - j'étais adolescent
donc j'étais déjà grand on n'avait pas
de téléphone mobile
mais bon et comment vous saviez vous
elle vous devez y aller et comment
comment vous échanger des messages
le monde et évolue tellement vite que
désormais on ne peut plus on peut plus
croire on peut plus se baser sur tout ce
qui a fait le passé on doit en
permanence s'adapter
c'est une bonne ou une mauvaise chose a
une manière de voir mais si on se remet
un peu en arrière si on reprend
justement cette accélération sous l'oeil
de la compétition la complexification la
collaboration qu'est ce qu'on peut en
déduire
et bien que les empires était une
tentative de collaborer de faire
collaborer les humains problème c'est
que les empires eux-mêmes sont entrées
en compétition sont devenus des
dinosaures les multinationales sont une
tentative de faire collaborer les
humains avec les règles du marché avec
la règle commerciale mais de nouveau des
règles de compétition
peut-être qu'avec internet il est temps
de passer à l'étape suivante à l'étape
de la collaboration à l'échelle
planétaire d'utiliser internet comme le
système nerveux d'un organisme
planétaire dont nous
on que les cellules alors c'est un rêve
et je ne suis pas le seul à le rêvez
vous avez sur l'écran ici la proposition
d'un designer suédois oscar perd 900
pour faire le premier drapeau de la
terre le drapeau de l'humanité que nous
soyons tous unis sous une même bannière
et se pose la question mais si internet
est le système nerveux
quid de la conscience où va se créer la
conscience collective la conscience
planétaire
alors il ya certes des tentatives sur
les réseaux sociaux
mais les réseaux sociaux appartient de
même aux multinationales
ils sont eux mêmes soumis à la
compétition peut-être qu'ils viendront
la conscience collective viendra sur les
réseaux sociaux libre comme mastodonte
peut-être que la conscience collective
apparaîtra sur la bvk chain cette
technologie qui permet aujourd'hui
d'échanger de l'information d'échangés
de la valeur sans aucune centralisation
peut-être que c'est ça l'avenir moi j'y
crois et ça ne vous pose la question
mais si nous y arrivons
si nous collaborons si nous avons cet
organisme collectif
la prochaine étape c'est bien sûr de
deux nouveaux recommencer le cycle est
de faire la compétition mais avec qui
avec d'autres intelligences planétaire
c'est pour ça que nous regardons les
étoiles
tout simplement parce que nous nous ne
sommes que des cellules dans l'évolution
de la vie parce que la vie a envie
d'entrer en compétition avec les autres
planètes et puis peut-être de collaborer
pour former une intelligence galactique
nous n'avons pas le choix nous regardons
les étoiles parce que nous savons qu'au
plus profond de nous c'est vers là que
nous devons aller
l'ingénieur russe konstantin tsiolkovski
disait la terre est le berceau de
l'humanité mais on reste pas au berceau
toute sa vie selon si je suis convaincu
que la vie formera une conscience à
l'échelle de la planète avant de
se répandre dans les étoiles il reste
une question est ce que nous serons
comme les dinosaures une tentative
avortée à un cul de sac de l'évolution
appelés à disparaître et laisser la
place à d'autres formes de collaboration
parce que nous avons voulu être trop
gros trop gourmand trop en compétition
ou est-ce que nous serons comme les
cellules cette étape vraiment
fondamentale qui a permis à la vie de
gagner les étoiles comme je voulais dit
la période similarités devient de plus
en plus courte
ça veut dire que ce choix nous devons le
faire très vite
contrairement aux dinosaures nous avons
conscience de ce choix nous avons la
possibilité technique de devenir une
intelligence planétaire aussi je vous
invite à réfléchir sur votre vie sur ce
que vous êtes vous ce que vous faites
dans votre travail
dans ce que vous faites dans dans la vie
quelles sont vos valeurs et qu'il est là
se pose dit se poser la question qu'il
est la partie d'entre vous consacré à la
compétition acquérir des nouveaux
marchés
acquérir de nouveaux clients vendre plus
produire plus on se met plus devenir
plus riche plus beau plus fort que le
voisin et qu'il est la partie d'entre
vous consacrer à la collaboration a créé
une humanité meilleure
quelle est la partie d'entre vous
dinosaures et qu'il est la partie
d'entre vous qui regarde vers les
étoiles
merci
[Applaudissements]